herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video in meinem letzten video habe ich
mir die wunderbare werke von james
britton angeschaut wer zum beispiel auf
so eine anfrage kann ich im rahmen beim
so etwas macht und in diesem video habe
ich euch gefragt wollt ihr dass ich das
auch mal mache ungefähr jeder hat ja
gesagt deshalb habe ich mich heute mal
ein bisschen hingesetzt und habe ein
paar anfragen dem ihr auf twitter
geschickt habt so gearbeitet wie ihr
mich darum gebeten habt oder vorstoß
geht wo ich noch kurz sagen dass ich
natürlich nicht auf einem level wind mit
jamie was photoshop geht an geht aber
ich habe mein bestes getan mehr wobei
ich hab ein bisschen schnell schnell
gemacht aber ihr werdet sehen
dieses wunderbare erste foto hat luca
mir eingeschickt er schreibt kannst du
mich als mp machen und fps mich
regierungsprogramm im auto unterwegs ich
sage natürlich nicht leichter als das
und fangen so leicht weil die schlichten
bisschen unterschiedlich aber ich habe
einfach das beste daraus gemacht hier
das ergebnis
ja also ich hab erst mal lukas koch was
dem körper getan und dann habe ich im
kopf wenn ich gut darin
dann lasst doch mal ein leica apo und
fertigkeiten donald trump ist wenn wir
noch mal auf das vorherige bild schauen
der kopf von finn war abgeschnitten und
deshalb habe ich einfach drauf bin und
weil auf dem heim kopf kann man keinen
ganzen kopf generieren oder so und ja
ich würde sagen ich bin sehr zufrieden
mit diesem bild vor allem mit sebastian
spieler aus dem t shirt auskunft habe
ich übrigens auch entschieden nicht zu
fehlen bzw
zeigen die ich bearbeite bringt immer
persönlich langweilig wenn man sich das
in irgendwelchen videos anschaut
übernächsten foto wurde ich angefragt ob
ich luca einmal lächeln lassen kann so
das hätte zwar nicht wirklich viel mit
photoshop zu tun weil die fed war aber
[Musik]
lukas plöchl steht hier auf jeden fall
hat man das interface werk gemacht dass
er gerne ich richtig richtig richtig
viel arbeit gewesen und ich habe
eigentlich immer so grundlegende
photoshop kenntnisse so gina schreibt
beim nächsten foto glaube der sieg
zusage aus und vielleicht braucht er
dann ein lätzchen der zu wenigsten foto
von sebastian der einen brutto lag dass
man frau elisabeth und ja anscheinend
ist dazu sauber gucken wir mal was ich
daraus gemacht habe ja wohl wie das
ganze auf ich dachte mir okay ein
kleiner junge der keine arme in sand
gespielt hat oder sowas und das papier
so ein bisschen dreck ins gesicht
gemacht und ein lätzchen angezogen ich
finde dass sie gar nicht so schlecht aus
also klar wie gesagt bin ich so auf
einem niveau diesen kranken menschen
aber das finde ich ganz wichtig um
kleiner junge vom spielen reinkommt und
ingrid rolex vermissten foto haben wir
einen luca der beim essen sitzt und
ausnahmsweise mal total hat es noch
nicht wussten immer wenn wir irgendwie
bloch aufnehmen halt nützlich heran und
die anfrage ist lose bitte ein fettsack
werden
ich habe mein bestes versucht dafür das
ergebnis also ja die muskeln sind ganz
gut verschwunden weil wir brauchen ist
ein wenig runder geworden ich würde
sagen man kann ihn auf jeden fall
deutlich mehr als verzeichnen als davor
order seite zufrieden mit meiner arbeit
generell fahrzeug das video gefällt mir
liebend gerne einen like nächste anfang
etwas was mir ein bisschen kreativen
freiraum gelassen hat macht den ph mal
hässlich und darauf ist ein foto von
luca zu sehen ich habe lange überlegt
und bin zum schluss gekommen dass ich
das bild so arbeite finde ich auch wenn
ich mit ihr machen wir das nächste
schnell nächste foto ihr merken uns wird
immer und weniger mach mal lukas zunge
länger was für einen
haare oder machen lukas ohne länger habe
ich gemacht
jetzt ist die zunge länger bis sehr
zufrieden etwas gebracht hat
aber ich würde auf jeden fall sagen die
zunge ist länger und extrem und
professionell gemacht sodass war foto
nummer sechs gehen wir doch mal zu
nummer 7 glaubt oder giftig ist handelt
sich diesmal um jemand anderen als luca
und formen baby wie wäre es wenn er
seine hand abdecken würde leute jetzt
aber auch ich mit lecken und zum mit dem
ergebnis völlig wir begannen zufrieden
aber ich habe es jetzt nicht besser
hinbekommen ja einfach nicht weiter
drüber reden und so tun als hätte ich
irgendwie photoshops geld bitte nicht
anfrage hat mich sehr gekränkt dann auf
dem bin ich zu sehen und die anfrage ist
lass ihn noch mehr wie ein pferd
aussehen mit einem foto von mir
persönlich abruft und erhöhe aber ich
kann nicht anders ich muss den leuten
helfen wenn sie mich darum bitten das
habe ich das drauf gemacht und ich würde
eigentlich sagen es wird auf jeden fall
mehr wie ein pferd aus ich habe einfach
gesichter ein bisschen verändert somit
so umformung schools und ja das ergebnis
ist ganz gut für mich
nach ihm einen bart also sie möchte
gerne dass sich luca ein bug verpasst
klasse das ergebnis also ich finde wenn
man ganz weit weg bzw
denn das bild ganz klein es könnte man
denken dass das ein bad ist und kein
scheitern sondern sich oder man sagt ein
paar fehler service spätere und jetzt
können auch schon zum gros final die
gleiche dame wie geben sagt bitte
verändere irgendwas mit der frau im
hintergrund gezeichneten bild auf dem
blog von luca wo wir beim essen warten
und die frau schaute ganz interessiert
schrägstrich verdutzt in die kamera
klappt gut überlegt und dann zog er sie
hat ja ihre arme so ein bisschen sondern
habe ich einfach keine raupe eingefügt
auf der sie reitet die reihe der hut und
fahrrad immer noch gut leute dann hoffe
ich mal dass euch gefallen hat weiß es
das getan hat las diesem video gerne ein
leichter und abonniert diesem kanal
hier findet ihr ein eigenes video von
hier und hier drüben findet ihren
abonnieren knopf habe ich irgendwann
schon mal gesagt das hier irgendwie
abonnieren sollte
[Musik]